Hello Freak bitches.
This part of the,
what I like about the Internet is like,
did you read or did you listen rather to the radio lab podcasts on Shiloh,
the mouth Lebouf and now I didn't answer the fucking great.
I sent it to Jamie.
It's fucking great.
What is it called again?
Twitter Truth trolls.
You have to find it because they took it down.
How do you take it down?
I just got enough.
You had it already downloaded on your phone because you've our auto download
Radiolab podcast,
so when I went to go find it I had to go search for it.
There was an,
I sent you that link.
They had taken it down the next day or something because people thought that
they were endorsing endorsing that trolling.
Yeah,
exactly.
They should be endorsing it.
It was awesome.
What the four Chan guys did was fucking amazing.
This is what they did.
Shai Lebouf.
So when I say his name,
whatever that fucking crazy assholes name,
he was doing some weird art piece where he like stood around with a bunch of
other people and it was like,
he will not divide us.
He will not divide us.
They would all say that.
And then all of these four Chan people found out about it.
So they showed up and started yelling a bunch of fucking Trump shit still up
live right now.
The camera's still on this one.
All after that whole thing ended,
they ended up like selling this to another company or our people when they're
handling all of it now.
So shy names not attached to any,
so this,
he will not divide us thing.
Right.
He would go to these places and say,
he will not divide us.
He will not divide us.
And people would show up and they would show up with like Keck is Stan shirts on
with pepe the frog.
They would wear make America great again.
Hats on.
And they weren't even necessarily Trump supporters.
They're just people trying to have fun,
right?
They're trying to fuck with people,
So what they did was Sheil above,
put up a flag in the middle of nowhere that said he will not divide us.
And then had a live stream where you could go and look at the flag as it's
waving in the breeze.
Right.
They found the fucking flag.
They found out where it was.
The way they found it was genius.
And it's all detailed in this radio lab.
The fact they took it down is actually making me mad.
Why would they?
Because what these guys did was awesome.
All right.
First of all,
it was brilliant.
They found social media posts that showed that people had met Shilo Lebouf in
some pieces that I say it's fucking name come off the bus.
They found out that they had met him in some weird place in Tennessee.
So they triangulated where he would be,
right?
So then what they did was they went around,
they had one of their members go round with a car and beeped the horn.
So they get to hear the horn on the camera.
And once they heard the horn on camera,
then they knew he was there.
Or then they knew that the fire was there.
So then they found out where it is by stars.
They looked at the fucking stars and they figured out where the area is because
when it's nighttime,
you could see the stars on the live feed and they figured out what constellation
it was.
They went to the fucking flag,
took it down,
put a make America great again hat on and a pepe the frog thing up there and the
guy walks up to the camera and goes,
Fuck Shai Lebouf
and that's the end of it.
So great.
The fact of radio lab took that down.
That's depressing.
Why do they do that?
Did they not understand what's happening here?
Here's a here's is how they did it.
So like when he was moving around,
they found the log cabin he was in and they're like,
let's look for rental cabins that matched the wood pattern.
They were around 3000 rental caverns in Lappin Lapland.
We just need to match the wood patterns easier.
Just,
they just spend time doing shit like this or animals.
I fucking love this.
I don't understand why they were mad.
Here's the how they did it too.
But,
but this one,
I understand.
I don't understand why radio lab would take that down.
Why don't you Google that?
Why did radio lab take down the Twitter truth or trolls?
Trolls,
trolls,
whatever the fuck.
So Ray,
you,
you're listening to radio.
I've never listened to radio lab,
but what is it?
It's an amazing podcast.
It's really good news.
Or it's one of my favorite podcasts.
They have all kinds of crazy shit on.
I mean they have stuff on all sorts of different inch,
oh radio lab removes its truth trolls episode from podcast feed.
And I suppose I was trying to find the actual cause it say why.
Yup.
They posted the reason why and this isn't second well what but it's saying that
they removed it,
right?
That was someone wrote in the article but obviously they removed it.
Editorial radio lab is decided to take down this episode.
Some listeners call this out saying that and telling the capture the flag story.
And the way that we did,
we essentially condone some pretty despicable ideology and behavior.
Aw,
come on to all the listeners who felt that way and everyone else,
please know that we hear you and that we take these criticisms to heart.
I feel awful that the things we said could be interpreted that way.
That's on us.
It was certainly not our intention and we apologize.
Come on folks.
You guys are missing the humor of this.
These,
these aren't despicable people.
They are saying things that are ridiculous because it's funny like there's a lot
of people that say a lot of fucked up shit online.
Do they actually mean this stuff or are they saying it because they are
anonymous and because it's fun to say fucked up things online that you're not
supposed to say?
I would say the latter.
I don't.
I think there's a bunch of people that are really legitimately fucked up online.
There's a bunch of other people that think it's fun because they're stuck at
some God damn soul sucking job in some fucking cubicle somewhere and they have
access to the Internet and so they go on message boards and they fuck around and
they troll this asshole Sheil above is a dumb dumb.
All right.
He's,
he's a fucking plagiarist.
I mean this guy has been busted for plagiarizing like giant chunks of other
people's work.
Right?
Like what did he get busted for plagiarizing?
He's a,
he's in jail every couple weeks for being an asshole and being drunk and like
fool.
Yeah.
I think that that Gig being a fucking movie star is insane.
I think it's insanely pressure filled.
It's way harder than what we do in terms of like dealing with all the people
that like you and managing all the relationships and brief history of Shai
Lebouf copying the work of others.
Yeah.
It's like a ton of shit.
What does it say?
He played your eyes an apology to Alec Baldwin in 2013 he bluffed roughly quit
what would have been his first Broadway show orphans due to creative
differences.
That is he couldn't get along with Alec Baldwin.
According to reports buff,
decided the best way to explain his departure would be to tweet out a photo of
his email apology to the cast and Baldwin by name.
Unfortunately,
parts of the prose sample a man owns up dot.dot.
A man Ellipsis,
a man grasps his mistakes was ripped off verbatim from a 2009 Esquire article
titled,
What does a man,
people including the articles,
author notice.
Hmm.
BARF.
Yeah,
that's,
that's not that bad,
but it is easy to plagiarize a bunch of shitty plagiarize his directorial debut,
his short film,
Howard can tour.com premiered in 2012 Cannes film festival until it was posted
online.
December 16th,
2013 that re,
uh,
viewers began to notice that the film is almost an exact adaptation of a graphic
novel.
That's what the one by Daniel Close,
best known for ghost world close told,
budge,
buzz feed,
which uh,
bought much of this story to public light brought much,
much of the story to public light.
The first I ever heard of the film was the morning when someone sent me a link.
I've never spoken or met Mr Leboeuf.
I've never seen even one of his films that I can recall and I was shocked to say
the least when I saw that he took the script and even many of the visuals from a
very personal story I did six or seven years ago and pass it off as his own
work.
Yeah.
Wow.
I actually can't imagine what was going through his mind.
He didn't apologize for plagiarism by plagiarizing a Yahoo answers post from
four years ago.
God,
he says copying isn't particularly creative work.
Being inspired by someone else's idea to produce something new and different is
creative work.
Uh Huh.
Well that's not totally copying what he said from the Yahoos answers,
but it's pretty God damn clothes,
whatever.
He's obviously got mental issues and whether they're real or whether he's
trolling or whether he,
whether he's having a psychological meltdown because of all the pressure of
being an actor,
this is a shitload of pressure and being in transformers
[inaudible]
yeah.